hi everyone I'm Ilana or Charl Amazon
and today you guys are watching my
review of castlevania lords of shadow -
something about the word lord makes me
feel like I need to say it that way I
don't know I also have some copies of
the game to give away on the Xbox 360
and ps3 so stay tuned until the end to
find out how you can win those for those
who haven't played Castlevania or even
the original lords of Shadow it doesn't
really matter the back story is pretty
well explained in one of the various
lengthy cutscenes from about the game so
as it turns out Dracula is depressed
paulla Dracula he wants to die miserable
after the events of the previous game
but can't kill himself hashtag vampire
problems so Dracula makes a pact with
this guy called Sobek who is able to
kill him that if Dracula defeats Satan
though Beck will kill him it basically
just feels really generic like Satan is
coming poor Dracula deal with it
so with a plot that's there that is
fairly mediocre the game really has to
hold itself together with the use of
exciting gameplay and for those who
don't know it is a hack and slash you
have the void sword which steals life
from enemies as you hit them and chaos
claws which are used to take out shields
and other basic defenses he also of
course has his trusty whip well all
these weapons are quite straightforward
and they don't really add anything new
it does really encourage you to swap
between the three quite regularly so
what some other games might have you
comfortably using the same weapon over
and over again that kind of isn't an
option in lords of Shadow 2 I really
like that it encourages you to use all
three and constantly mix up the way the
game plays aside from that there's also
a new stealth mechanic and aside from
being the first game where you play this
Dracula it's also the first game to have
this and it just feels out of place Drac
you're looking hide in the darkness and
then possess a rat and then possess a
giant satanic cyborg thing and while
it's kind of cool it once again goes
against this plot where you're playing
is Dracula it makes you feel weak like
you have to hide but we've always been
taught that Dracula is supposed to be
this super badass slay everyone kind of
guy in most other aspects it's really
similar to the other
Vainio games it's twisted extremely
gothic and honestly kind of miserable
one day Dracula starts out looking all
decayed and old so you're forced to one
of the streets and consume a terrified
innocent family and that's quite early
on in the game the twisted nature of the
game is actually pretty alluring and
it's definitely enough to keep you going
through some of the fairly simple
puzzles that are present but while the
combat itself is really fun and the
world is beautifully gothic and medieval
the biggest flaw here seems to be that
castlevania lords of Shadow 2 tried too
hard they put it all this stuff that is
sort of out of place and half-assed
you don't really care about that much
when instead they could have had more of
the really really awesome platforming
elements that go into some of the
puzzles and the beautifully polished
combat like the modern-day setting of
the world if you leave Dracula's castle
you just in a modern day and it's quite
open wild after a while but it just
really lacks that distinct gothic
atmosphere and if that was present
consistently throughout the game it just
feels so much more polished but the game
as a whole for a 15 to 20 hour game is
just really ok there's nothing that's
outstandingly bad about it but there are
noticeable flaws but after all about if
you would still like to win a copy of
the game I have two xbox360 copies and
two PS 3 copies to give away and when
you guys to tell me in 25 words or less
what you would do if you were Dracula
for a day I don't know but I feel like
this is a pretty hard question to answer
so I'm excited to see your responses
unfortunately because shipping is
ridiculously expensive as always I can
only let this one be open to Australian
residents make sure you check your inbox
because I will be unboxing the winners
to get their addresses so I can send you
out your prizes I'm also giving away one
copy of each on my Facebook page so if
you would like to find out more about
that my facebook is linked below but
that is it for me today you guys I will
see you all next time bye